Charlotte Rose Rui I
chose cosplay me
ni
[music] I'm
still playing, of course
I can't lose to a woman like that After selling the housing complex
ah ah ah
it's hard why am I dressed like this  I have to do this
, so please give it to everyone, because it's a big deal, so I'd like you to take
a look at it.
Well then, it's not embarrassing even if you don't look at it, it's bad
Aono Dancho witch girl looks good, isn't it?
I don't know anything about men's hearts Men
are weak against gaps
.
A shining star,
what is this sky?
Ah,
well, I don't care about this,
I'm disappointed that I went to school and ended up in a draw, but I held on to it,
did you think that the darkness had changed a little?
Ai-san is the
draw, so I'm
black and white,
yeah yeah no